So, the idea here is to enable the creative impulses that the technology turns loose,...
...and get the law out of the way.
The work of Creative Commons is really about...
...laying the infrastructure and groundwork for this new type of culture,...
...a new kind of folk culture.
Somebody from Delhi, somebody from New York, somebody from Singapore...
...can feel comfortable using a photo that was created and...
...given away by someone in the United States, or in China,...
...or wherever that the license has been extended to,...
...with their identity being preserved.
Which means that people can actually...
...create new kinds of things, come together and build things.